hi in this video we are going to talk
about
the t cell receptor gene rearrangement
so here is a t helper cell
which has its own t cell receptor right
and its
core receptor cd4 for t helper cell the
core receptor is ct4 or the cytotoxic t
cell the core receptor is cd8
but our focus is tcr today not the core
receptor
now the t helper cells sole
job is to recognize antigens
which are displayed on two class two mhc
molecules
by the antigen presenting cells such as
this dendritic cell
so this dendritic cell would present
extracellular antigens which are derived
from pathogens maybe
and the t helper cell would recognize
that pathogen derived antigen with its t
cell receptor now imagine this thing
there are many different pathogens
present in this environment
and each time the dendritic cell or any
other antigen presenting cells
are sampling these antigens derived from
diverse pathogens right so each time
the tcr is presented with different
kinds of antigen such as depicted here
all these different three different
scenarios
shows that how difficult it is for the t
cell receptor
to recognize these pathogen-derived
antigen
because because each cases
these antigen could be different right
now that is why the t cell receptor
need diversity need to generate
diversity
but the question is how the diversity is
generated at the tcr level
and the answer is gene rearrangement
which can possibly generate these
diversities and i'm pretty much sure
that you guys know
that b cell receptors or antibody genes
undergoes
vdj recombination if we look at the tcr
gene segments just like the bcr gene
segments
they are also having vdg
segments so let me first tell you the
alpha beta chain
of the tcr is act directly in contact
with the antigen
as a result the alpha beta gene segment
is undergoing vdj recombination and
that's the point for diversity
just like the b cell receptor heavy
chain and the light chain gene segments
we have t cell receptor alpha beta
gamma and delta gene segments which have
vdj components and they can undergo vdj
recombination
now vtg recombination takes two
important
consideration vdg recombinations
first and foremost criteria is to have
signal sequences
that would initiate the recombination
process and obviously
rag 1 and rank 2 recombinase are
important because without the
recombinance enzyme how recombination
would take place
it turns out both these components are
present
in t cell suggesting towards the
possibility that t cell can undergo vdj
recombination as well
and this vdg recombination is taking
place in the tcr
alpha and beta chains now
let me tell you what is the advantage of
undergoing vdg recombination
and how diversity can be created so
there are different type of
v segments d segments and j segments
right so let us assume that
here the v segments are actually v
1 to v n d segments are d 1 to d n and j
segments are j 1 to j
n so in each recombination event
different combinations of v
d and j can be combined
to form a new type of tc
tcr receptor now both the cases the tcr
would have the alpha chain and beta
chain but these alpha chain and beta
chain
are little bit different from each other
and this
origin of diversity make sure that
these two tcr's have differential
affinity towards an antigen
and that is very important for the t
cell
response now the question is where does
the vdj recombination takes place or
where does the
t cell rearrangement take place tcr
rearrangement take place
and it turns out that t cell development
take place in the
thymus right now inside the thymus
definitely the rearrangement is taking
place
now t cell first of all commits to its
lineage
in the cortical region and not signaling
turns out to be
important for this phenomena after
lineage commitment
t cell undergo several stages
first stage set of stages are known as
dom double negative stage
in this double negative stage
in the d1 double negative stage 1 to
double negative stage 2
transition they undergo beta chain
rearrangement
now after that after the double negative
stage four they undergo the alpha chain
rearrangement so these alpha and beta
chain rearrangements are happening
two different temporal points
and inside the thymus
other than alpha beta rearrangement
there could be also
gamma delta rearrangement as well but
the gamma delta rearrangement is
extremely rare because there are two
rearrangement events that need to happen
now already
the probability that the gamma delta
chain would be formed is very less
so gamma delta tcr containing t cells
are also very less
they are comprising roughly 25 percent
of the total t helper cells
so roughly we have two type of t cells
alpha beta t cells and gamma delta t
cells based on what type of gene
rearrangement has occurred
in their t cell receptor and even if
they are alpha beta t cells
the affinity of alpha beta tcrs are
different in different set of t
cells and that leads to diversification
of detection in terms of different
antigens
now the gamma delta t cells are
extremely rare and after but
their number decreases sharply whereas
alpha beta
t cells they increase in number now
let's compare these two
alpha beta t cells and gamma delta t t
cell receptors
for a little bit details now alpha beta
tcr rearrangement is more likely to
occur compared to a gamma delta tcr
rearrangement
now definitely alpha beta t cells are
higher in number compared to
gamma delta t cells and ultimately
alpha beta tcrs are more diverse
right and in terms of antigen
recognition
they play crucial role not gamma delta
tcr but
gamma delta tcr has their defined role
in the prenatal phase in the gestational
phase
so both of these combinations are
important so in this video we kind of
appreciate that just like
the b cell receptor t cell receptor also
undergoes vdg recombination and that is
one of the mechanism by which
antibody or that is the one of the
mechanism by which
diversity in terms of antigen
recognition is taking place
and we also looked at exactly which
temporal window this kind of
recombination event is taking place
and where it is taking place so if you
like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe thank you